it is inevitable that you will get
dementia
no no and no never smiling
steps of wrinkles wrinkles are not as a
result
of smiling even if it is do we really
want to stop smiling
you don't need as much sleep when you
get older you
always need sleep hi my name is dr
alicia arbaje
and my name is dr abnorfing and today
we're going to be debunking
myths about aging it's harder to learn
new things
as you get older it may be a little
slower on some things especially if
we're not familiar with them
but as we get older we become more able
to understand things that are more
abstract as opposed to concrete
so i think this bodes well for older
adults as uh dr
bailey said i think it's just different
older adults
are more likely to learn things faster
that don't have to do with technology
but once technology comes into play it
takes them a bit longer
how you age is predetermined by your
genes
this is one of my favorite ones to talk
about
i think that genes are way less
important than we think
and lifestyle is way more important than
we think
and we have the ability to turn genes on
and
off how we eat sleep live
love and exercise makes the biggest
difference of all
so your habits from youth play a key
role in how your aging
process goes it is inevitable that you
will get dementia
no no and no dementia is not a normal
part of aging and it's important to
understand that if you're having
memory problems or problems planning or
being oriented or getting around
that is a sign that something needs to
be checked out only a small
percentage of older adults actually have
dementia
so if you have problems with remembering
things
you need to understand that it could
also be due to an underlying problem
that can be solved you shouldn't
exercise
when you are older because you are prone
to
injuries if you have underlying
conditions your wealth
is important you pay attention to the
exercises you do
because your underlying condition might
affect your risk of
injury but old age alone is not a risk
or injury
i wholeheartedly agree and would add
that there are different kinds of
exercises no matter
what situation you are in you could be
bed bound or in a chair or in a
wheelchair and still be able to do
different kinds of exercises
you don't need as much sleep when you
get older you
always need sleep and the amount of
sleep you need over time
is probably going to be pretty
consistent and the way
to know if you're getting enough or not
is to understand
how well you're doing the next morning
are you able to function the next day
and do the things that you have to do as
we go into sort of retirement
most of the time we have more time
available to us during the day
and many times we take more naps than we
should as such we should be able to
adjust our daily habits
to ensure we don't spend most of the day
sleeping and then not be able to sleep
at night
you gain weight because your metabolism
slows down i feel there is a chance of
weight gain
not because your metabolism slows down
but because you are more inactive at the
time
we need to still remain active the older
we get
your metabolism should also stay pretty
consistent
throughout our lives so i really think
that this can empower people
to not feel like old age is going to be
about
a lot of decline the next myth is that
people lose their sex drives as they age
so this one's kind of interesting if
people are losing their sex drive per se
it could be because of an underlying
chronic situation
a chronic condition it could be related
to medications
people's relationships change over time
and what becomes
important to them may change or evolve
over time
it doesn't necessarily mean that they
wouldn't have a sex drive
i totally agree with dr abahi the sense
that people may have
different interests and different ways
of showing affection
the older they get and again there may
be underlying conditions that may make
sexual intercourse not as comfortable as
it used to be
so getting old makes you grouchy
we see how older people are depicted in
cartoons and in movies
and often this is the stereotype i don't
like
this desk and i don't like this chair
and i don't like holidays flippity flop
and they flew with the equality
we realize that a majority of our
patients are not grouchy
but they seem to be a bit sad because of
the you know
the nesting syndrome being alone in the
house and things like that
but crouchiness is not a feature of old
age
that is so well said grouchiness is not
a feature of old age
i do think that depression is a lot
higher
in older adults or it can be and that
can be because
of underlying chronic conditions life
circumstance
and those are things that depression can
manifest as irritability in
older people and that may be mistaken
for grouchiness
you will lose your eyesight losing
eyesight is usually related to a problem
in other organs as well so it's a sign
of an underlying condition
poor circulation or diabetes or high
blood pressure or strokes
now what we do know is that the acuity
of your vision
can change over time so the sharpness of
your vision
but that is not the same as losing your
eyesight you may
have certain visual impairments
but not loss of eyesight and all these
impairments have corrective measures
that can be applied
to ensure your site returns if not to
normal
to almost normal so your teeth fall out
as you get older again there's a popular
saying over here
meaning you don't prepare for war in
time of war
meaning you prepare for old age before
you get old
most of the time people take care of
their bodies or seem to neglect oral
health
and that's why it seems that most times
people lose their teeth
your teeth are so important because all
those bacteria
travel to other parts of our body so
it's really important
to keep as i said earlier all our organs
in good shape
and that will help our teeth stay in
good shape as well
aging means more medications so
this one is unfortunately partially true
but it doesn't have to be it does seem
that the older people get and the more
health care they receive the more
medications they might end up on
the theme here is how you eat how you
sleep how you exercise how you love how
you pray
all of these things matter even if you
are on medications
that there is still a chance you can
come off of medications with
lifestyle changes so anyone who's on a
medication
i just require encourage them to see
their health care provider
geriatrician ideally and ask several
times a year do i still need this
medication and if i do do i still need
it at the same dose
and if i still need it what else can i
do in my life so that i can eventually
come off of this medication if possible
interestingly i was thinking the same
thing that tabari was thinking and so
it's important to note that if you have
a healthy lifestyle
you are less likely to require most of
the medication many elderly people take
at the moment
because you have prevented the
conditions that require them
never smiling steps of wrinkles
wrinkles are not as a result of
smiling even if it is do we really want
to stop smiling because smiling has so
many other benefits
wrinkles are about loss of collagen loss
of hydration
and not so much how you're using your
face so please don't stop smiling
and please instead hydrate if you're
worried about wrinkles make sure you're
eating plenty of fruits and vegetables
really skin is an inside job eating
fewer calories will extend your life
what we know is the kind of calories you
eat
are more important than how many so our
bodies run
on glucose and the more pure sources of
glucose
you can consume the better fruit has the
most
bioavailable source of glucose available
to our bodies
and when i say eat way more fruits and
vegetables i mean
way more four apples three mangoes
six potatoes like not this tiny side
salad stuff that we think about
make that the majority of your meal it
is hard to get
fresh produce all year round depending
on where you are and it can be more
expensive for some people
i am not saying that it's important to
eat organic although if you can that's
even better
but i don't want people to shun getting
access to whatever kinds of fruit and
vegetable they have
preparation is the key to success so and
so
your lifestyle what you do your habits
your form
before you get older that go a long way
to ensuring you have a healthier
and longer life adjust your attitude
about aging
we have this idea that aging is about
decline
and being dependent on other people
aging is a beautiful part of life it's a
time when we become more wise
when we become able to give back to
others and
we are as geriatricians are here to
support you